la garrigue au juste on va revenir sur
la sonal parce que je sais que ça vous
tient à coeur
la semaine dernière on va on va revoir
ses petites phrases dans la revue non
mais est ce que vous voulez les revoir
ou pas c'est bon raquel vous voulez vous
expliquer maintenant cliquer oui non
mais à l'ol ce que j'aimerais que voilà
trois ans dans le vif du sujet alors on
va revenir sur ce qui s'est passé cela
dit laurence ça y est on parlait de jean
michel blanquer
laurence ça y est vous avez posé une
question oui je demandais s'il venait à
y assister la tard puisque je pense
qu'il mène un combat contre le voile
excusez moi allez c'est bon de rêver je
me situe le continent le gros problème
avec moi parvenir tout le sommet ghz et
ciblant au caire avaient dit non mais je
reste une contexte va comprendre si
blogueurs avaient d'ipad qui part en
sortie scolaire
est ce que vous auriez démissionné du
poste qui vous a été donné par le
président de la république
voilà ce que j'ai dit j'ai posé la
question à yassine belattar exactement
celle là raquel garrido a dit lassé
importe non parce que par admettre les
articles mais si on disait que j'avais
imaginé mais le cas d'un papa portant la
kippa alors que dans le ciel dit eric et
là vous savez à de la musa verrou moi
j'ai pas parlé dès juin n'avait jusque
là pas et son équipage thaurac l1 pape à
l'esiee nous replacer le contexte
brouillon qui nous rejoignent vous s'il
vous plaît et là vous avez dit raquel
j'avais dit s'il avait dit ça il serait
plus au gouvernement
eh bien il se serait fait virer oui
bernard laporte a réagi tout le monde a
réagi de la table laurence ça y est eric
naulleau
voilà pour dire que c'était des propos
qui nous semble et antisémites je vous
le dis c'est vrai ça veut dire quoi vous
à ce que nous on la prie je vous dis
comment l'après ici pour bernard pour
eux eric pour laurence on l'a pris il y
a donc un lobby tellement puissant qu'il
aurait été mineure alors que la voilà il
s'est rien passé pour lui dans ce qu'on
a dit on temps où les revenus donc
premièrement merci parce que
effectivement c'est pas moi qui me suis
mis à parler d'un papa imagine important
là qu'il ya un mois de cela c'est
laurence c'est pas moi non plus qui
parle de lobby juif
ce vocabulaire qui est un vocabulaire
classique de l'extrême droite
ou c'est pas mon vocabulaire qu'est-ce
que vous à la mairie depuis que de lobby
juif
bon alors expliqué sétois cyril qui a
parlé de crise c'est comme ça qu'on l'a
pris bernard tu la 1ère
le progrès c'est impossible pendant
laquelle c'est les juifs bénéficient de
protections dont ne bénéficient pas les
analyser la phrase autrement alors vas
dites-nous raquel expliqué ben moi je
trouve que c'est quand même assez
limpide je pense que l'antisémitisme
c'est la sphère de nous tous d'accord
moi je déplore jeu absolument je déplore
la petite concurrence qui s'installe
entre les victimes de la discrimination
et de racisme
donc il faudrait que ce soit les films
ans seulement qui défendent les
musulmans victimes de racisme
il faut que ce soit que les juifs qui
défie lutte contre l'antisémitisme mais
lier marion à la partie la question ta
question laurence au fond ce que c'est
ça que tu soulignes est à te
sous-entendait que yassine belattar il
en avait finalement rien à [ __ ] des
juifs et que et qu'en fait il vraiment
des combos derrière on est en question
conférence des victimes
je pense que l'antisémitisme là tout
sens l affaire de tous ses potes tu
réponds pas à quel touché au mollet dieu
cette noise
il entre dans ces cas là il aurait été
démis de ses fonctions ça veut dire oui
toi reviendra ou non mais quand vous
avez vous apprends rien moitié vient de
plus que ce que j'ai dit je pense donc
ses côtés alors c'est que vous m'avez
non attendez attendez les mots terminé
dans les règlements ce que tous nous
tous nous tous ici autour de la table
nous aurions demandé la démission de
blanc quercy blanc car avait avait dit
que c'était pas souhaitable qu'un pape
apportant l'axé pas à une sortie
scolaire c est nous l'aurions réclamer
tous à cor et à cri et nous leur aurions
sans doute peut-être peut-être obtenu
séparés bien que l'arrivée et tous les
signes religieux la différence parce que
tu quelle loi la loi noix les
propositions de lois quoiqu'elle
maintenant je suis j'ai emmené tous les
cinémas inventé le personnage imaginaire
du papa pour ça va être assez mais deux
mois non c'est toi de la loi sur la
concurrence gvh identive concert moi
c'est moi j'ai laissé les fraises par
doit nous a tous mis le double samedi là
je suis choquée on avait tous demandé
pourquoi parce que l'antisémitisme nous
concerne de ces pierres là ce que c'est
très grave
d'accord pas moi je le jure qu'elle sait
vous contentez d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
cyril moi moi ce qui m'a le plus choqué
dans cette façon de jeter c'est un matin
cet anathème contre moi ce mot
antisémitisme
c'est que pour moi l'antisémitisme c'est
pas une opinion dont on organise
tranquillement la contradiction si tu
penses que je suis antisémite il faut me
virer sur le sueur bah oui souvent
chambre il ne pesait pas acceptable qui
est des antisémites
autour de la table de balance donc on ne
peut pas sortir sur des amphores le
racisme mais quand même c'est pas vrai
qu'un lobby juif
ben moi je pense pas qu'elle vous
préciser à la même justin n'a pas été
prononcé qu'on peut dire en fait je suis
à des années lumière dans ma pensée mais
votre propre créature y aller